- We have been around
each other too many times
for me not to know that you were a dancer.
- Oh, well, yeah. Yes.
- Yes!
- But I don't tell people that.
- Oh, I'm sorry. Let's go
ahead and bring up this photo.
Yep. Look at that chest hair!
- [Neil] Oh!
- [Kelly] Look, out to play!
- I had no idea!
- Wait, Kelly, that was 50 pounds ago.
- Whatever!
- If you could measure
time by weight accumulated.
- Wait, were you talking
like that to the dancers?
- No, no. I was a performing member
of three different dance
companies in my day.
- That's amazing!
- In another day,
in a different chapter of my life.
- Yes!
- Yes.
- Groovy and you can groove. I like that.
- Well, no, I like that.
There's nothing like dance shape.
'Cause you're strong, you're
limber, you're flexible.
- Yeah.
- And graceful. And so-
- Totally, just like me.
(audience laughs)
Just like me, that's what I say.
- By the way, when, when
I was dancing, by the way,
I was still studying astrophysics
and I had fellow dancers
who were making extra money
'cause I needed money.
'cause they weren't paid much.
- Yeah.
- And one of them said,
why don't you come down with us?
'Cause some of them
danced at a strip club.
- Oh my God.
- Like a guy strip club
where the women-
- Do you have a picture?
- No, no, Kelly!
No, no, no, no.
But I just wanted like clarify.
- Make it my birthday.
- No, no, let me clarify that.
So I went and I was cut and flexed.
I could do a full split.
- Oh!
- But I went to just investigate.
- Yeah.
- Right.
I wanted data first.
- Yeah.
- So I go there-
- Data?
- Yes! So I'm watching them come out
and they had asbestos lined jockstraps
that had been ignited with lighter fluid
and they came out dancing
to Jerry Lee Lewis's song,
"Great Balls of Fire."
(audience applauds)
Now, now, now let me just say-
- Oh my God, this place is awesome!
- I'm embarrassed that only in that moment
when I saw their genitals on fire
did I say, "Maybe I
should be a math tutor."
(audience laughs)
- Maybe there's another way.
- I didn't think that before that.
But that's stupid.
- You're using your dance skill.
- I could totally tutor math
and it didn't occur to me to do so.
- Now I'm gonna be honest with you.
Like, I've never been to a strip club.
Not against 'em, do your thing.
But I've never been to one.
But like, if I were to go to one,
I don't think a lot of
balls are being on fire
at a lot of them.
I think that was a very
specific strip club.
- I'm just saying, at that point,
I had other thoughts
about how to earn money.
- You're like, "I'm gonna
keep this junk safe."